wenn man es eilig hat und wann hätte man
es nicht eilig das leben ist so kurz
besonders nach 5 uhr also wenn man es
eilig hat dann kommt sicher etwas
dazwischen
[Musik]
und jetzt gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
entweder man friert die nerven
pd
sind schon verloren oder man bricht
sämtliche rekorde maschinenschreiben
noch mal schnell durchlesen und auch die
interpunktion sitzt ja jetzt aber tempo
als wirt peter da sagen mit einem
bärenhunger diesem jahr eine frau hat
zwei lebensfragen was soll ich anziehen
und was soll ich kommen anscheinend
kommt auch der appetit mit der ehe
ja und das aller wichtigste für ihn ist
der pudding richtig und dann bekommen
eine zeugin wie schnell und man stellt
uns die frage wie schmeckt auch einer
50er jahre doch öfter werbung hashtag
plattform so leidet das nicht zu diesem
video inspiriert hat war dieses
kommentar seit etwa einem jahr als timo
veröffentlicht wurde und er immer wieder
in den videos vorkommt wirkt sie auf
mich wie so eine alte emotional sehr
abhängige ehefrau die youtube machen
muss um das geld nach hause zu bringen
weil ihr partner arbeitslos ist
community ich tat das was jede sehr
abhängige ehefrau tun würde
ich habe gegoogelt und habe eine drk
werbung aus den 50er jahren gefunden wo
frau den adel ihren peter ganz viel
pudding macht da sind sehr viele
kreationen sehr viele schöne polin
kreation und ich dachte mir ich habe
noch nie so einen richtigen richtigen
schönen pudding gemacht ich hab mal so
ein pudding pulver angemischt und weiß
ich dass eine schüssel gemacht und dann
halt im löffel gegessen aber da in
dieser dr oetker werbung zeigen sie wie
man pudding so richtig schön präsentiert
und dafür hab ich ein paar form geholt
und zutaten und jetzt werden wir mal
gucken wie schmeckt der dr oetker
pudding aus der 50er jahre drk werbung
mit frau renate einfach
und jetzt freuen großes champagnerglas
und dass ich mich liegen kann hat und
wiesen wald und wiese
[Musik]
da wird damit tag und für alle die mich
jetzt gerne irgendwo melden wollen weil
ich werbung machen und die nicht
kennzeichnen
ich stand noch nie mit dr oetker im
kontakt bis zu diesem zeitpunkt aber
nach diesem video können sie sich gerne
bei mir melden wenn sie eine neue frau
renate brauchen wir pudding und kane
speisen einfach oktober angefangen mit
dem schokopudding den ich sehr schön
findet weil er so eine tolle form hart
und sehr präsentabel aussieht und dafür
habe ich einfach so ein gugelhupf
silikonform geholt ich habe noch nie so
einen steifen pudding gemacht auf der
packung vielleicht sollte ich einfach
weniger werbung machen
auf der packung sieht man so einen
starken pudding dann muss es ja so ein
streifen bringen geben da ist die
abfahrt ein begriff schaue ich sag's wir
die zubereitung ist wirklich kein
hexenwerk wir müssen halt pudding machen
[Musik]
ich habe noch nie so viel pudding masse
gehabt habe ja schon bei wie schnell
selber gemacht aber da macht man zum
beispiel auch mit eigelb und so bleibt
muss hier auch begraben
ich sollte auch wenn über vegan zu reden
wenn ich zwei liter milch in einem topf
aber ganz ehrlich das ist auch ein
bisschen heuchlerischen aber jetzt mal
schnell hier der pilger kommen gleich ob
die milch kocht und jetzt ein ganzer
tross problem
die vorsitzende in der werbung soll der
pudding aber viel dunkler aus während
die nummer eins auf dem balkon steigt
wird das keyset kümmern wir uns um den
pudding in der glasschüssel mit den
schönen kirchen drauf und den
sahnehäubchen wir haben uns für sagen
wir haben zur sahnepudding entschieden
und es ist nicht kirchen saison deswegen
haben
tk zwischen ja und jetzt machen wir das
gleiche nochmal mit hafer mit dem
benutzten hafer milch weil ganz ehrlich
ich habe auch keine wirst 100 liter
milch zu verwenden
und ich will unbedingt wissen ob es auch
mit habe aber nicht funktioniert
[Musik]
2000 alu pinkeln ich mir vorstellen
würde das team nach der arbeit josef
zimmer kommt an dass er arbeitslos und
ich dann so alles von vorteil
die hat ja noch sehr begabt wie renate
aber was ist das sind am 15
was waren die 50er jahre da musst du
deine frau daran arbeiten und dieser weg
daran vorbei wenn sie die werbung in den
50er jahren gesehen hat am 28
habt ihr den pudding gemacht wieder
auffällig legen finden noch mal auf der
heißen stelle aufkochen lassen und schon
ist der veganer pudding fertig gott
leute und hier ist pudding nummer zwei
ich weiß gar nicht warum ich so rum
stehen aber ich glaube weil es so heiß
hier live paket butter kuck mal wer ist
schon zerstückelt gewonnen ja wir machen
jetzt unser drittes er und zwar in
götterspeise ich habe diese form dafür
geholt weil das einfach auch glaube ich
extrem geil so man so ein riesen
götterspeise turm hat altmeister
geschmack götterspeise in den topf
nummer drei einfach nur zucker wasser
wir verstehen sehr heiß
perfekt und während unser wackel vor den
jetzt auf dem balkon brandherd kümmern
wir uns um die nächste götterspeise und
zwar die rote da gibt es in dieser
werbung nämlich aus dem glas wunderschön
hergerichtete götterspeise und jetzt
machen wir das was für die ganze zeit
gemacht habe ich neben putzer und
flüssigkeit und damit für das zusammen
und dann kommt es ist noch nicht der
spaßige teilnehmer personal 3d werden
safe mit gleiche flüssigkeit kommen und
alles mit dem tod oder ist gefallen die
erste ab geht die luzie und wäre beim
letzten training sind schreibt mir mal
bitte in die kommentare
was für ein image ihr von mir haben also
wenn ihr zum beispiel jemanden von
meinem youtube-kanal erzählen wollen
würde oder von mir
was würdet ihr dann sagen schreibt gerne
in die kommentare interessieren nicht
wirklich langweilig sogar ein video
darüber
und wenn ihr schon da unten seiten geht
dem video einen daumen nach oben und
vergesslich diesen kanal zu abonnieren
und die glocke zu aktivieren und
wirklichkeit meiner neuen videos mehr zu
verpassen
[Musik]
videos habe ich schon gemacht werden
dass endeavour mit 876 tausend
abonnenten
seit gründung des kanals am 25 januar
2012 hat diese 192 millionen 500 an
60 1807 aufrufe auf 437 uploads erhalten
437 und abgeben und ein paar stunden
wieder wenn alle sachen live sind es ist
der zweite tag und wie ihr unschwer
erkennen könnt habe ich mir noch mal
extrem viel mühe mit diesem outfit
gegeben aber es geht hier nicht um mich
auch wenn ich das gerne so hätte wir
werden jetzt die pudding stürzen es ist
synchron-finale wir fangen mit dem
schokopudding okay leute mich stört ist
jetzt und ich bin so aufgeregt
okay ich habe was gehört mainka wie hoch
der eigentlich sein soll eine
silikonform ist vielleicht nicht die
beste idee aber er vorbild schön und ich
weiß dass für pudding sie in der banken
verwendet haben weil da war viel dunkler
so richtig dunkle schokolade kollegen
sie haben natürlich keine kosten und
mühen in dieser werbung gescheut und
haben sprühsahne verwendet
[Musik]
das gute ist was ist der guglhupf formen
das heißt kann die vanillesoße kein
kippten hier beim aalener enterprises
wird natürlich nicht an kosten und mühen
gescheut und auch wenn du versuchst
produziert das ist eigentlich voll die
geile alternative zu seiner torte mit
sahne obendrauf wir uns ausschnitte sind
läuft das immer raus ist eine richtige
torte und jetzt kommt's torte
wackelpudding
ich krieg den aber nicht aus dieser also
wir stürzen einfach mal ich weiß nicht
ob es irgendein trick noch gibt den ich
nicht beachtet habe aber wir stürzen wir
stürzen wir stürzen
wir haben gestürzt jawohl ich glaube ich
mal passiert ein messer ein bisschen
locker machen
auf jeden fall oben am rahmen versuchen
nochmals das ist auch eine ganz tolle
form hier also superschön
genauso habe ich mir vorgestellt
aber ich sag mal so kleiner tipp ein
bisschen vanille sauce macht eigentlich
alles wieder gut
er wird sich jetzt aber gut stürzen
lassen das habe ich im gefühl genug an
den rat ihren fans super sturm
großkampen wagen warten wir ab wenn
jetzt darum herum mache ich mir immer
die mühe mit kuchen die dekorativer
pudding macht arbeit und werde unsere
sprühsahne treiben sonst ja spricht dann
aber nur so um mein gott das sieht so
richtig kalt weißen hauses gibbs
excuse als nächstes kümmern wir uns
unseren sahnepudding der ich glaube ich
auch echt gut stützen lassen würde
kirschen sehen heute leider nicht mehr
so gut aus wie gestern bei den kirche
habe ich akzeptiert ist ist nicht saison
bei den erdbeeren tut es mir leid ich
weiß nicht warum man überhaupt noch
findet die sehr lecker der ist es auch
nicht so schwer zu dekorieren da machen
wir sahne und kirchen drauf
[Musik]
und die kirschen
aber ihr könnt mir nicht erzählen dass
das nicht schön ist unser letztes
experiment was glaube ich einfach das
beste experiment geworden so
wackelpudding im glas und ich bin total
überrascht weil ich auf die kirschen da
rein gemacht und die sind hoch
geschwommen und sind halt so steif
geworden
ich finde dass sie total dekorativ auge
haben wir einmal ja in so einem café
glas immer den rest und wieder ein
sondern silikonform stürzt jetzt einfach
mal an ich weiß nicht ob ich heute
stürzen gesagt hat ich glaube silikon
und wackelpudding verhält sich nicht und
schon ist das eingestürzten
wackelpudding sehen
so soll es geht schon sie ja schon viel
besser aus und springt aber das ist auch
gut und spektakulär
ich sag mal so man sieht dass ich kein
profi bin
aber ja
rowling ist kann man nicht anders sagen
der ist schön wer ist schön wer ist
schön du bist wunderschön
du bist ok und du bist irgendwie ist
auch da und nun stellen wir uns wieder
der allerwichtigsten frage wie schmecken
calling kreationen aus einer doktor
fünfzigerjahre werbung denn ihr wisst
eine frau hat zwei lebensfragen was
ziehe ich an
und was koche ich heute mehr ist da oben
nicht los sonst ist funkstille
timo ich habe probleme macht instabil
was unterschied ist dass du für mich
gepackt
dabei so schwer arbeiten carla pudding
und braucht daher gehen wir haben noch
mehr
keine sorge werden freunde die uns
diesen polen auch gerne abnehmen ich
glaube man geht da einfach so rein
erdbeere sahne
[Musik]
das schmeckt wie eine erdbeertorte ist
und nur diese nur erwerben die creme
mitnimmt ohne den kuchenteig ja das mag
ich mich wieso wir sind dafür
vertrocknete kleinen parteien kirchen
sind da wie das ist leider wie ich mache
meine portion in eine schale
so ist man das kaufen will sowie kämpfen
kann wieso soll ich die übergeben wenn
diese kürzel dfe
es ist eine ganze mal tief gefroren
hinzu kommt dass mit mir dann kriegst
jetzt einfach so und ich kann mir jetzt
einen usenix hätte ja sowieso ein
kuchenteig ist eine dusche kommt auch
darauf an sprit ihn lecker da gibt es
noch ein bisschen salbe weiter mein
zweiter klick nötig
[Musik]
dafür bekam diese flashbacks es ist wenn
die kinder aber wir haben das gleiche
auch noch einmal in grün als auch
nochmal ganz speziell auch weil ich weiß
dass man in den usa aufwerten schmeckt
noch besser als diese kirchen
kombination einfach so ausgedacht aber
das ist das große finale
da sind wir stark alles sehr lecker wer
viel auch reichlich dafür wird man der
mann wird seit der muss nicht vor hunger
der ist auch nicht besorgt der ist von
den der computing aus hals nasen ohren
raus das ist super leute das war's danke
meinen arbeitslosen mann wir mal einen
job vielleicht damit ihr euch youtube
videos machen muss um deinen arsch
mitzufinanzieren okay wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder ich auf euch hat
gefallen
es war eine interessante folge die große
politik show und wenn ihr bis
hingeschaut hat möchte ich kommentare
lesen die sich auf kinos
arbeitslosigkeit beziehen
vielleicht jobangebote stehen
ausschreibungen das gleiche
tipps und tricks für ihn ja das wird
[Musik]